TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi there.
I'm Timothy Jordan, a Developer
Advocate here at Google.
And as you probably know, I like
to do videos for developers,
helping to educate and
inspire around our platforms
and services.
And I'm here with
Marques Brownlee.
MARQUES BROWNLEE: That's funny.
I also make videos, so I think
it would makes sense for us
to make a video
at the same time.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I
don't see why not.
And in fact, let's start out
in one of my favorite areas,
Android Wear.
So here we are in the
Android Wear area--
really big watches, which
is, I think, pretty cool,
and, of course, a normal
size watch on my wrist.
Now, I want to show
you one of the new apps
that we launched recently, which
is Google Maps on Android Wear.
If I just tap on the
watch, load up Google Maps,
you can see, well,
the first thing
is that it's Maps on the
watch, which is pretty cool.
But also, I can set it
up so that the compass is
following me.
As I kind of turn
my wrist around,
or I look different directions,
the map goes with me.
Also I can zoom out.
I can zoom in.
I can look at local places.
And this is a key thing-- if
it goes into ambient mode,
the map is still
there on the watch.
And it's going to update
once every minute.
So all I need to do is glance
at my watch, whatever mode it's
in, and I know where I'm at.
MARQUES BROWNLEE: Very nice.
And I'll tell you
what, that compass mode
is going to be really handy
for me, because I have
a terrible sense of direction.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It happens.
Oh, there's Clem.
Hey, Clem-- hey, how's it going?
This is Clem Wright.
He is a Product Manager
on Android Wear,
and this is Marques.
He is awesome.
MARQUES BROWNLEE:
All right, so I've
heard a little bit
about an app called
VimoGolf on Android Wear.
I was hoping maybe you
could show me how it works.
CLEM WRIGHT: Yeah,
sure, so this uses
the accelerometer and
gyroscope in the watch
to track your golf swing.
So go ahead and set up.
Get your stance right.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: This is great.
We know, Marques, that you're
a little out of practice,
so don't worry
about being perfect.
CLEM WRIGHT: Awesome,
yeah, so, as you see,
we can watch your swing
played back here on the phone.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That is so cool.
You know, you're still
in the swing of things.
MARQUES BROWNLEE: I
told you I still had it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK, so here we
are in the Google Cast area.
And now, you know Google
Cast is a great way
to control your media, such
as your TV shows or your music
from your phone.
Well, now it's also a
great way to play games.
And Marques is actually playing
Driver Speedboat Paradise,
and he's about to beat my time.
Hey, Nathan, could you-- you
really need to meet Nathan.
He's right here and--
oh, you-- that's too bad.
So Nathan here is a Product
Manager on Google Cast.
Nathan, could you
tell us a little
why this game looks so great
on the television right now?
NATHAN CAMARILLO: Yeah, Google
Cast Remote Display for games
allows game developers to
harness all the great GPUs that
are in a phone and render
great looking content
not only to the local device,
but directly to the television.
It's available for
developers now,
and it's really easy to use.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Well, we should
back to this game.
Is it my turn yet?
MARQUES BROWNLEE: I was just
about to beat the record, too.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh,
that's right, OK.
Go for it again.
So here we are in
the Android TV area,
and we're all playing on the
NVIDIA Shield Android TV.
And of course,
it's a racing game,
so Marques is kicking our butts.
MARQUES BROWNLEE: Yeah,
it's a racing game.
I've got to be on
top of my game.
But I'm curious, since this
is a new NVIDIA Shield,
if we crack this thing
open-- not that we would--
what would we find inside?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Krispy?
KRISTAN KRISPY
UCCELLO: Well, you'd
find some very excellent
NVIDIA engineering.
They've brought their X1
processor to Android TV
and packaged it up
in a form factor
that consumers
are going to love.
It plays everything
from AAA titles
all the way down
to casual games.
And as the Play Store expands,
the number of games available,
consumers are just going
to love this thing.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Awesome, well, I'm
going to get back in the game.
[CHEERING]
All right, Marques, here we
are in the Android Auto area,
and I promise you we're going
to get in one of these cars,
so you can text your mom.
MARQUES BROWNLEE: That's
exactly what I need right now.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So it's
looking pretty busy.
But I know these
guys really well,
so it shouldn't be a problem.
MARQUES BROWNLEE: Let's do it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hey, Andy.
ANDREW BRENNER: Hey, Timothy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: The car's
looking pretty good.
ANDREW BRENNER: Thanks.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hey, so I've
got my buddy Marques here,
and I just wanted to
give him a quick demo.
ANDREW BRENNER: Timothy, you
know the last time we gave you
a car what happened.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Woo,
hoo-hoo-hoo-hoo-hooo.
ANDREW BRENNER: You
can borrow the car.
But it has to stay here.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
ANDREW BRENNER: All
right, here you go.
Remember what I said.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I will.
Thanks, Andy.
So here we are at
the home screen.
You can see we get Nav.
We can head to the airport.
We've got weather, recent calls.
MARQUES BROWNLEE: It looks like
I also have a text from my mom?
CAR: Here's the message.
How's the conference?
MARQUES BROWNLEE: Reply--
it's going pretty well,
but I'm a little bit busy.
I'm driving Android Auto Car.
CAR: Here's the message--
well, that is so cool.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: For more
information about anything
in this video, hit me up
on Google+ or Twitter.
Also check out Marques
Brownlee's Quality Tech videos
on his YouTube channel.
And, of course, don't
forget to subscribe
to the Google Developers
YouTube channel, as well.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]